[Musique]
en pâtisserie ou en boulangerie on
utilise fréquemment des levures pour
donner une texture aérienne au pain ou
au gâteau mais certains boulangers
amateurs ou professionnels ne jure que
par le vent où on priorise beaucoup le
vin impact elle parce que c'est plus
digeste le prince conserve plus
longtemps salle ajoute beaucoup d'arôme
au pain le vin faut le lire il ya des
matins qui est en forme et des matins
qui l'est moins un peu comme nous
stéphane la jeunesse est un boulanger
amateur qui a appris à faire de la
boulange avec de la levure conventionnel
avant de faire la transition vers le vin
on peut enfin son propre de 20 en fait
il ya des livres qui comme en fait c'est
pas très compliqué du moment où ce qu'on
mélange de l'eau et de la farine
tous les ingrédients sont déjà présents
pour faire un levain les
micro-organismes secte yves et la
fermentation commence comme le pain au
levain à une et dix glycémique réduit il
est plus digeste la levure elle est un
champignon qui provient de la
domestication du levain la 9e qui donne
un raccourci son voeu mais je trouve que
moins de complexité leur goût avec la
levure le boulanger junier roi d'automne
boulangerie de montréal fait tousser
pain avec du levain sauf ses pains
baguette mais il faut du temps et de la
patience pour faire et entretenir son
levage celada conserver au un petit peu
delevaque quand on dit que c'est vivant
on le voit leurs lois vivre qui est
spécial à propos de ça c'est que ça
d'après ammar
l'environnement y vit âgée de 8 ans le
level utilisé chez automne est
relativement jeune
si on le compare à certaines
boulangeries qui ont des lgv est
transmis de génération en génération on
le conserve à température pièce 24
heures sur 24
simplement rafraîchir avec de l'eau donc
il faut vraiment une aubaine pour le
rafraîchir pour par le suis vite ça
c'est la seule quantité que je conserve
le fait pour le boulanger amateurs qui
ne boulange pas tous les jours
l'entretien du levain se fait de façon
différente sans miche par jour dans le
conserver au frigo et ça nous permet à
ce moment-là de nourrir uniquement une
fois par semaine c'est seul vin que l'on
appelle le levain chef
ils servent de base pour confectionner
le pain alors on prélève de levain chef
fin grâce auquel on a joué 50 dirhams
dont les 50 g de farine et on fait ça la
veille et le lendemain matin on de la
quantité requise pour faire notre pain
sans toucher à voir depuis ça c'est
parti depuis lors chez les partis ce
matin donc à peu près huit heures on
peut déjà voir il ya déjà quelques
semaines doublé en volume selon julien
le levain de goût unique qui révèle les
saveurs florales des farines d'ici
qu'ils utilisent
ça va être un pet qui va avoir une ligne
un peu plus serré mais beaucoup plus
goûteuse qui voit se conserver beaucoup
plus longtemps
puis qui va avoir une vie plus humaine
qu avec la levure pour que c'est
vraiment dans la complexité du goût on
reconnaît un bon pain puis le ss
allemands c'est un peu la passion qui va
aller avec parce que ça prend plus de
temps ça prend plus de patience pour
arriver à un prix qui vont être
meilleurs qui selon mes goûts
le goût du pain au levain et plus
assidus que le pain à la levure
on sait qu'au québec on est pas des
fanatiques de goût acidulé dans le vin
ne nous est pas de goûter le vin d'un
goûter des farines qu'on met en place
dans nos pétrin on retrouve vraiment
goûté de la farine donc on met le
moindre de leurs impossible on utilise
la plus longue fermentation possible le
levain jumelé à une longue fermentation
apporte au point certaines
caractéristiques bien identifiables on
voit que la coloration est vraiment très
uniforme le bon processus de
fermentation
mais c'est surtout parce qu'on voit que
ce pantin qui essaient depuis les deux
principales vont être tenues crude qui
est pas mal plus épaisse que quand on
utilise la levée c'est le principal si
on coupe
est ce qu'elle est on va voir une
couleur ou une texture diaries l'on voit
que les avions sont vraiment répartie
manière uniforme dans la partie alors
que si on utilise dans l'horreur de la
manière standard on va avoir des grosses
alvéoles mais pas régulière c'est un
groupe jeune et c'est quelque chose que
je trouve et qui est encore plus
artisanales afin son intérêt pour les
farines locale de qualité conçus
spécifiquement pour le pain a poussé
stéphane à tenter l'expérience du pain
au levain
il nous fait goûter de ses pains au
levain frais du jour c'est une farine
que pauline blanche et chimiquement
donc c'est pour ça que l'intérieur est
plus jeune crème celui-là
comparativement à ce que l'on voit à
l'oeil entre que c'est très bien que
c'est beaucoup de prudence en fait c'est
une farine qui a été juste légèrement
anisé donc on peut voir la différence de
couleur l'ennemi commun c'est beaucoup
plus compact très goûteux
oui avec une bonne croûte bien craquant
effectivement c'est ce qu'on recherche
aujourd'hui ce style-là de paix
je dirais c'est ce que les gens
cherchent à faire à la maison
c'est ce qui nous fait en boulangerie
puis c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce métier
[Musique]